after decades of research and billions
of dollars spent in clinical trials we
still have a problem with cancer drug
delivery we still give patients
chemotherapy we're just so nonspecific
that even though it kills the cancer
cells it kind of kills the rest of your
body too and yes we have developed more
selective drugs but it's still a
challenge to get them into the tumor and
they end up accumulating and the other
organs as well or passing through your
urine which is a total waste and feels
like mine have emerged where we try to
encapsulate these drugs to protect them
as they travel through the body but
these modifications cause problems that
we make more modifications to fix so
what I'm really trying to say is we need
a better drug delivery system and I
propose rather than using solely human
design why not use nature's immune cells
are these versatile vehicles that travel
throughout our body patrolling for signs
of disease and arriving at a wound mere
minutes after injury so I ask you guys
if immune cells are already traveling to
places of injury or disease in our
bodies
why not add an extra passenger why not
use immune cells to deliver drugs to
cure some of our biggest problems and
disease I am a biomedical engineer and I
want to tell you guys a story about how
I use immune cells the target one of the
largest problems in cancer did you know
that over 90% of cancer deaths can be
attributed to it spread and so if we can
stop these cancer cells from going from
the primary tumor to a distant site we
can stop cancer right in its tracks and
give people more of their lives back to
do this special mission we decided to
deliver a nanoparticle made of lipids
which are the same materials that
compose your cell membrane and we've
added two special molecules one is
called ISA lectin which acts as a glue
that binds the nanoparticle to the
immune cell and the second one is called
trail
trail is a therapeutic drug that kills
cancer cells but not normal cells now
when you put both of these together you
have a mean killing machine on wheels to
test this we ran an experiment and a
mouse so what we did was we injected two
nanoparticles and they bound almost
immediately to the immune cells in the
bloodstream and then we injected the
cancer cells two men with the process
through which cancer cells spread
throughout our bodies and we found
something very exciting we found that in
our treated group over 75% of the cancer
cells we initially injected were dead or
dying it compares to the only around 25%
so just imagine these fewer amount of
cells were available to actually be able
to spread children part of the body and
this is only after 2 hours of treatment
our results were amazing and we had some
pretty interesting press my favorite
title was actually sticky balls may stop
the spread of cancer now I can't tell
you just how smug my male colleagues
were knowing that their sticky balls
might one day cure cancer but I can't
tell you they made some pretty pretty
exciting pretty ballsy t-shirts this was
also my first experience talking to
patients where they asked how soon our
therapy will be available and I keep
these stories with me to remind me of
the importance of the science the
scientists and the patients
now our fast-acting results are pretty
interesting but we still had one
lingering question can our sticky balls
our particles actually attach to the
immune cells actually stop the spread of
cancer so we went to our animal model
and we found three important parts our
primary tumors were smaller and there
are treated animals there are fewer
cells in circulation and there was
little to no tumor burden in the distant
organs now this wasn't just a victory
for us and our stick you all's this is
also a victory to me in drug delivery
and it represents a paradigm shift a
revolution to go from this
using drugs just injecting them and
hoping they go throughout places in the
body to using immune cells a special
delivery drivers in your body for this
example we use two molecules East
Lexington Trail but really the
possibility of drugs you can use are
endless and I've talked about cancer but
where does these go so do immune cells
so this could be used for any disease
imagine using immune cells to deliver
crucial wound healing agent after a
spinal cord injury are using immune
cells to deliver drugs pass the
blood-brain barrier to treat Parkinson's
or Alzheimer's disease these are the
ideas that excite me about science the
most and from where I stand I see so
much promise and opportunity thank you
[Applause]